An Ai has probably judged
your resume already.
Hello World Saroj and what does
the perfect resume look like?
We'll build an AI app to automatically
rates the value of a resume using
advances in natural
language processing or NLP.
The first generation of hiring systems
required a lot of human effort hiring
teams would need to publish their open
positions to newspapers and the cable
networks.
Interested candidates would then apply
to the position by sending in their
resumes.
These resumes were then reviewed by the
hiring team and the best candidate was
called in for another round of interviews.
The second generation of hiring systems
introduced the concept of hiring
agencies.
They offer a solution in
which the candidates submits
their resume to an agency.
The agency would act as a middleman.
They would screen resumes and send to
candidates to suitable positions at
different companies.
But now we're in the age of a Ai.
We are reaching the third
generation in hiring systems.
Candidates can upload their resumes to
an AI system that uses natural language
processing to assess the
capability for a specific job.
A company could then use this tool to
call in the best candidates for further
interviews. I've got so many
rejections, but look at me now.
This removes the cost for companies in
hiring an agency and results in a faster
candidate pipeline.
It also serves as a great tool for job
hunters rather than trying to use your
own intuition and trying to gauge
whether certain parts of your resume our
optimal,
you can just use a tool to analyze your
resume for you and tell you what areas
need to be improved on for this
specific job you're applying to.
Red Score is one startup that does that.
For candidates.
They can improve their chances of landing
a specific job by using their tool to
optimize their resume and
on the recruiting side,
sovereign does the same for
companies looking to hire candidates.
So how do we do this?
Rule based parsers are a traditional
way of screening resumes automatically.
That means that a developer
will line-by-line write out
a set of if l statements
that check for certain requirements
in a resume and if enough of those
requirements are met for
a given preset threshold,
then the resume moves on to the next
stage of the interview process else.
It's tossed aside,
but the problem is that there's a lot
of variability and ambiguity in the
language used in resumes.
There are different ways to write
dates and different job and skills.
A pure every month someone's name could
be a company name or even an it skill.
The only way for a resume parser to
deal with all of these edge cases is to
truly understand the context in which
words occur and the relationships between
them.
No rule is 100% reliable except
the one about fight club.
Machine learning solves this problem by
estimating the quality of these signals
based on annotated data and by combining
the evidence from several signals,
we can call these signals features.
They are the encoded information that
is relevant for a prediction task.
Lots of different machine learning
techniques require us to decide what these
features are beforehand.
In fact,
two of the most important aspects of
machine learning models are feature
extraction and feature engineering.
Those features are what supply
relevant information to the ML models.
We can represent the word
overfitting for example,
using various different
feature representations
and LP tasks like automatic
summarization and topic extraction have
generally required developers to sort
their corpus of text and two different
feature groups like bigrams and trigrams.
If there are too few features,
that model will have a hard
time making a useful prediction.
If there are too many,
that model can be slow and overfit
stay balanced with the force.
We don't really know what
feature representation is
best for a given task and in
the off chance that someone does, it
still relies on a human being in the loop.
Ideally,
we just want to be able to give a raw
data set to a model and have it produced
an insights without any human help.
Deep learning though allows these features
to be learned automatically for image
classification.
For example,
handcrafted features were required for
any model like detecting edges but with
convolutional neural networks.
Edge detection is instead learned
by the first convolutional layer.
The filters learned to buy the first
layer of CNNS when given images are very
reminiscent of Gabor filters which were
used for edge and texture detection
traditionally and for the next layers,
the filters begin to recognize specific
patterns and objects with increasing
detail.
All of these are learned feature
extractions as the features become further
refined as we go up the model hierarchy.
The change here is that architecture
engineering became the new feature
engineering.
Rather than having data scientists
figure out the for deep learning,
they have to figure out the most
suitable hyper parameters for the model,
like the learning rate
and the filter size.
In a paper from last year called domain
adaption for resume classification,
a group of students from Finland,
Sweden's jealous younger sibling,
proposed a method for classifying
resume data of job applications into 27
different job categories using CNNS.
Even though CNNS are normally
used for image related tasks,
we found that they can work well
for text classification as well.
If we think about how we would
assess a resume before anything else,
we need to make sure that the resume is
a right fit for the specific role we are
hiring for.
Once we have that we can assess the
amount of experience that candidate has,
the quality of the brands they've worked
with in the past and the quality of
their past relationships.
So let's start with this basic example
of automatically weeding out resumes that
aren't a fit for our specific role cover,
how exactly it works.
Then talk about ways of improving it.
Collecting training data for our resume
classification use case isn't easy.
Resume data is difficult and costly to
obtain because it's considered sensitive
information,
but data about job descriptions
can be obtained much easier.
The two domains constituted by
resume data and job description data,
however are intrinsically related.
Both domains are related to the
same job recommendation task,
which is to match applicants
to suitable job offers.
The resumes of applications have semantic
similarities with job descriptions,
which belonged to the same job category.
They both contain skills,
education duties as well as personal
characteristics of the desired candidate.
So it seems reasonable to use transfer
learning in order to implement a domain
adoption in order to leverage
the information contained
in the huge amount of
labeled job description data.
In order to classify resume data.
That's exactly what they did.
They collected 90,000 job descriptions,
snippets using the indeed job search Api.
It enables access to short
jobs summaries given a keyword.
The keywords they used were 27
different industrial job categories like
accountants and insurance to very
boring jobs for testing the model.
They use an anonymized data set
of about 500 resume data samples.
Each sample labeled with one of the 27
categories based on the type of job that
candidate is looking for.
So the goal was to leverage easily
available job description data to train a
model for classifying resume summary
snippets to better understand how the two
domains deferred.
They mapped out word frequencies of all
words appearing at least five times in
both datasets.
The results showed that in resumes
people were much more likely to use
adjectives describing themselves
as adaptable and polite.
Whereas job descriptions more often
mentioned roles like director and
coordinator.
An interesting finding.
The training data consistent of lots
of words like lots and lots and lots.
If we observe these
words with the human eye,
we're able to tell which words
relate to which other words.
We're able to categorize certain words.
That's because our brains have built an
internal representation of the intrinsic
meaning behind words,
so we can tell that even if two
words are spelled differently,
they both have the same meaning.
The way machines can do what we do is
he use vectors as that representation.
This is a group of numbers and abstraction
that is learned from learning word
meaning mappings.
Word two VEC is a pretrained
model that did this.
It learned word vectors from a
huge collection of generic words.
Using this model, when you give it
a word, it'll output it's vector.
Turning words into vectors allows us
to perform calculations on these words.
I'm talking addition,
subtraction,
numerically defining how
similar one word is to another.
Math is my city and converting
our words into vectors.
Then feeding those vectors into art.
CNN is an important preprocessing step
as it's a numerical representation.
Perfect for the Matrix.
Operations will apply to it throughout
the neural network board propagation
process.
So once we use word to Vec to
convert our words to vectors,
we'll build a convolutional network using
Carol Ross to then learn the mapping
between those word vectors and the job.
That category label the model did pretty
well and anybody can train their own on
a cloud training service like Google
cloud or Floyd hub pretty easily given a
new resume,
it's converted into a vector fed into
the model and the percent likelihood that
it belongs to a certain
job category is output.
If that percent is over a
certain threshold we predefined
than it valid for our
job.
This alone greatly increases
the efficiency of the
hiring pipeline still here.
Awesome.
Three points to remember.
Natural language processing is a subset
of machine learning that lets us extract
insights from text data rather
than engineering features.
We can let deep learning learn relevant
features and focus on tuning model
architectures instead.
And the hiring pipeline currently requires
lots of unnecessary costly effort.
There's a massive,
massive opportunity to use
machine learning to make
the process more efficient
for both candidates and recruiters.
It is midterm time for this course.
This week's coding challenge is to write
a script that classifies text using a
CNN. Details are in the read me get
humbling scope in the comment section,
and I'll announce the top two entries
next week. You made it to the end.
Hit subscribe to be my friend and
you'll never be lonely again. For now,
I've got to attend Google io,
so thanks for watching.